[Music]
the problem was that in three days we went
from having the hostel 100% full to
having it empty, that's why it was
announced that all the schengen borders were going to be closed,
all our
public, which is mainly European,
left and didn't  Not only that, but we also
had to continue paying the contribution of
electricity, water, gas, telephone, all the expenses, and
also our employees were going to spend
with them, they were going to get married, but
we continued to pay, the salary, it is
essential that the European Union have
the Schengen borders open on 85
Percent of our public comes from
outside of Spain, from the Union, without those
open borders, we cannot deal with it,
we are super excited, we are really
looking forward to opening on June 18,
we know that the Schengen borders are going to
be open and that all that public
that  we haven't had for this year and a
half is coming back
[Music]